cbs news is learning about new steps the
biden administration is taking to try to
ease the growing crisis at the border
the administration is directing shelters
to fast
track the release of any unaccompanied
child
to a parent or legal guardian willing to
care for them in the u.s
manuel bajorquez is just south of the
border in juarez mexico
manuel what are you seeing there
well good morning every day we see
people trying to cross
into the united states some looking to
turn themselves
into border patrol hoping they can ask
for asylum
others looking to evade those agents and
the youngest
are caught in a humanitarian crisis
this guatemalan boy believed to be about
six
was seen walking alone along the train
tracks crossing from juarez
into the united states many
unaccompanied minors like him who the
biden administration has allowed to stay
while their cases are processed
end up in overcrowded facilities like
this one in donna texas
the administration plans to convert a
convention center in san diego
into a fifth shelter to house migrant
children this just shows
how completely ill-prepared the byte
administration was
for what's turned out to be an
overwhelming tidal wave
of the number of migrants who were
coming across the border republicans are
demanding access to the minors who are
being held
texas senator ted cruz is leading a
group of senators to the border on
friday
they're hoping nobody sees
the tragic human cost of their failed
policy
meanwhile senior biden administration
officials are traveling to mexico and
guatemala
to discuss with government officials
ways to reduce the number of migrants
traveling to the u.s vice president
kamala harris said the administration
inherited
serious challenges we've got to treat
this issue
in a way that is reflective of our
values as americans and do it in a way
that is fair and it is humane
um and and but we have to to meet the
moment and
there's a lot of work going into that on
monday we met this honduran family who
had sought asylum
in the united states after two
hurricanes slammed the region last year
they had just been expelled from the u.s
i feel worried because you have a fear
of being out on the streets
sleeping on the streets he said
some families say they are fleeing
threats of violence in their home
countries other simply that the pandemic
has decimated their towns
and work opportunities the biden
administration says most families
will not be allowed to stay gail
it's a very tough situation there too
thank you manny reporting from juarez
mexico